So last June, as I was strolling by Lake Lugano on the way to ICML 25, I was wondering, how
are we going to improve on our CAR-T cell therapy?
There's a session.
So I'll present the data.
Why do we want to improve on this?
We know that loss of CD19 antigen is seen in about a third of patients with DLBCL post-CAR-T
relapse.
So adding another targeted epitope makes sense.
So what I'm going to review are the three sort of what I feel are frontrunners, the
CHI product, the Janssen, and the Miltaini product.
So the CHI product is interesting because it's a bisistronic leniviral vector.
It encodes an anti-CD19 CAR that has a CD28 co-stimulatory domain and an anti-CD20 CAR
that has a 4-1-BB co-stimulatory domain.
So what was primarily presented was the phase.
Phase 1B portion, the dose expansion.
And I am moving fast because I'm trying to review three presentations in seven minutes.
What I will point out is that the dose level three, there were 26 patients.
They did allow patients who, this was second-line therapy, and that was approximately half of
the patients in that group.
And they did allow bridging.
They did allow bridging therapy, which, again, approximately half the patients received that.
Oh, sorry, here it is.
So 58% in dose level three received the bridging therapy.
There were some patients who had prior CD19 CAR-Ts allowed on trial.
So what did we see?
We actually saw pretty low incidence of grade three ICANS or CRS.
So 4%, 8%.
All results.
So this is a little bit more overwhelming.
What about responses?
So on the left of this slide, they're looking at the CAR-naive patients who are in the dose
level three.
78% achieved a CR, the others you can see.
And looking at dose levels one and two, 36% achieved a CR.
If you look at the 18 patients at dose level three who are CAR-naive, they're a six-month,
five-month, six-month, six-month, six-month, six-month, six-month, six-month, six-month, six-month,
duration of CR rate was still at 71.4%.
So that was a brief summary of the first dual CAR.
So next we get into the bispecific CARs where the two epitope binding domains are within
a single transmembrane protein.
Here I'll review the J&J data.
Initially this was, there was a Chinese study.
It was a study that looked at enlarged B-cell lymphoma that had a very high response rate
at 86%, which led to this leading to this trial.
So in this global phase 1B study, the presentation mostly focused on the fixed dose at 75 million
CAR-T cells, and there were 25 patients in that group.
Again, I will point out that it did allow one patient.
There were patients who had only had one prior line of therapy, and in the fixed dose cohort
that was right at 50%.
They also allowed bridging therapy, which again was slightly over 50% of patients.
The rate of CRS was actually quite low.
The grade three CRS was two patients.
With regards to ICANNs, again, very low toxicity was seen.
What about the response rate?
So when you look at the recommended phase two dose, they saw a 77% CR rate, or an overall
response rate, you know, closing in on 100%, so quite well.
Looking at a swimline plot, you know, you see very good responses, and some are very
durable at the time of the report.
So moving on to the third CAR.
And I have two minutes and 34 seconds to review this.
So XamtaCell.
Again, this is a single, or it's a dual epitope-binding single transmembrane protein.
What is unique about it is that it is a fresh product.
It is not pro-preserved.
So the vein-to-vein time on average was 13 days, so a much more abbreviated time to infusion.
They did allow bridging chemotherapy, but that was only in 5% of the patients.
They were fairly high-risk patients in general.
You always have to wonder.
You're giving bridging chemotherapy while patient's product is being made, so there's
a risk there.
But what they did demonstrate is that all of the patients were treated.
91.3% were within specification, and the other 9% were still treated with their plant-based
product.
And again, the viral copy number, important to note that it's not too high, which increases
risk with your product.
So what did we see?
An overall response rate of 72, 73%.
The CR rate was 50%.
When you look at the medium progression-free survival, it was 9 months, but in the, of
course, with the CR group, it was greater than that.
When you look at the median duration of response, again, 11.4 months.
What about toxicity?
There was a single patient with grade 3 ICANs.
There were, no, actually two patients.
There were no patients who developed grade 3 CRS.
So in summary, and I'm keeping it under seven minutes, these are three what I consider front-running
products.
So the CRS was very manageable, typically low-grade.
The CRS was very good.
The CRS was very, very good.